this video was sponsored by one dream
more on that at the end of the show
previously on tom scott plus i thought
i'd got through without having cold
water in my eyes
oh no that's that's what sucks okay
lovely oh that's that's incredibly
unpleasant oh that's cold okay cool
oh
how am i getting cold water shot off
that's that's genuinely i need to
probably sit down that got real very
quickly what happened there was just
sudden
body nausea
and
almost like my brain started to shut
down it was like stop this now oh i
hate saying these words i can't
physically do that you should take the
camera team onwards yeah
i'll walk around with this with the crew
i am going to be grumpy about this for a
long while
so i'm back
i never really thought that you would
come back but i'm really happy that you
decided to take on this challenge again
it feels like unfinished business
and i have every i just know that you're
gonna do this this time i'm glad you did
so okay i could have spent the last
months like doing cold water training
and building that up what i've actually
done is relied on technology i have a
full layer of three mil neoprene nail
socks wetsuit
gloves yeah so i'm very very warm right
now and hopefully that's gonna work down
there yeah i know it will because you've
become so prepared you know this time
that it's just gonna work out
i hope it's not undiagnosed
claustrophobia that'll be that'll be bad
but
we'll find out today and it'll be a
journey for both of us and you'll get
through it i just know you will i wasn't
nervous until about five minutes ago
when we came back here but um just to be
clear we have the same safety team as
last time uh we have mostly the same
crew helping us around are you ready
i i i will never not be more ready than
this oh that's the cautious cautiously
phrased guarded answer to that all right
so if you'd like to follow me let's
let's do it down the slide all right
i'll get down the side you don't have to
go down ah well i will it's it's just
it's not it's not a good slide it's uh
it's not a good slide bbc did not pay
for a good slide no
is it me or is it muddier down here than
last time it's very much muddy do you
happen to like mud i've got three mil
and neoprene i'm indifferent to mud at
the minute that's brilliant that's a
good sign
okay i'm fine just just boot actually
stuck in the mud there that's that's
great that's that's lovely that's a
normal thing i i promise i'll tell you
what elise
last time
last time we're here obviously wet cave
a lot of cold water
i got a load of
emails from american cavers no way who
were like i can't believe they took you
down into a wet cave that's so unsafe
yeah but this just seems like normal for
brittle so this is in my opinion one of
the safest caves in the uk
because it's so well explored but you've
also got so many flood warnings before
it floods and water is all around
derbyshire yeah which is where we are so
in actual fact this is probably one of
the safest caves in
the the in the area that we could go to
the americans just seemed really freaked
out about the idea of a wet cave in
general well americans they don't have
wet caves like us british people
unfortunately
so here we've got buxton water sump yep
now this is where we cleaned off last
time i remember this yeah so a lot of
cavers use this sump to their own
benefit by cleaning their clothes after
they've got money when was this built
because this was this is clearly built
well i'm not sure when this was built in
fact our team might have a lot more
knowledge on when this particularly was
built but the sump itself the water has
always been here right and someone just
put a dam up to make it yeah yeah so
that we can use it to our own advantage
so last time i started to freak out when
i got water in at the mucky ducks down
there yeah when the water came into your
boots yeah so
i'm going to do that here this time yeah
and test the new gear and make sure that
i if i freak out here
that's fine we love this space if i
freak out there
so cool all i need to do
is exactly what i've been doing
like training at home here
which is
wade into the water
and
uh sit down
i can literally feel the water just
steadily rising inside the suit so this
is a lot more gentle
i think i'm gonna be okay here but
that's what i said last time so let's
just
all right
i just felt the air bubbles escaping
yeah there's the cold water okay okay
how do you feel i'm fine breathe through
it i practice this like i've been
sitting in an ice bath in this wetsuit
at home oh my god
okay
it won't get any worse than this
temperature yeah
so i mean the good thing is
neoprene socks are working yeah
stomach's a bit cold
but
that's okay brilliant let me just move
about a bit redistribute the cold water
it's not pleasant
but
straight down my back
yeah okay i can live with this
are you feeling confident to go through
more than i was i think i'll
now i know that i'm okay from cold water
shock
i just need to know that it wasn't
claustrophobia and the only way to find
that out is
through there yeah
i'll be with you every step of the way
let's do it yeah let's do it oh right
down my back
ah
i am now carrying an extra half kilo you
know for shooting with every step so the
water will soak up but it'll get to your
body temperature yeah and now we are
approaching the part like oh this is
this is the mucky ducks basically this
is the way you had a bit of trouble last
time got a bit of trouble this time it
will happen i promise you it will uh
you'll be a fantastic
i'm
i'm nervous because this is the point
where things went wrong last time yeah
but i'm
i'm not the heart rate's not it well but
it wasn't last time i was absolutely
fine until halfway through at which
point something went wrong yeah and i
think it was just cold water shot
that's it just catch yeah i
okay so just be aware there are lots of
rocks you can't see in the water yeah
which is why i go slowly it's fine i can
put my hand underwater
and it's not
the freak out it was last time because
it doesn't feel cold yeah
this is fine this is fine this is fine
this is also the shallow bit
oh there's that rock
every time yes that rock just there yeah
that's so annoying right
i mean i was already having a panic
attack last time at this point this is
where you sat down yes
this is the point
where i was sat down here having a
breather yeah and i don't need one so
let's take this is good this is
brilliant let's keep going i'm loving
this you're going
the water doesn't feel as high as last
time either no it doesn't i think we've
had a bit of a dry spell recently
which is fantastic
lots of silt though yeah i'm just kind
of going on hands and knees through here
i'm fine
oh okay yeah but that's uh there was no
hand hold there i think maybe you got
the right idea i oh i can't believe i
got through this last time with uh
okay yeah yeah no i'm good i'm good
and that is through and warm
thank you elise ah
yeah
i'm good last time i was sat here for a
long time
recovering
and i'm fine
i'm absolutely fine yeah you are
so well done last time there was a load
of stuff through there yeah that i can
get to see there's one more wet bit
right yes there is and save your team
all right you're not going through that
you're not going through that yeah i'm
glad they made that call no then totally
right call but i'm
yeah yeah so next one is higher just a
little bit not too much that's fine not
too much to worry about i'm fine i've
even got my microphone wet
let's go i'm excited hold on i'm excited
yeah i'm going fast and every single
time i've had like a proper injury in my
life like the scar on my face
it's because i was in this mood and it
was like yeah let's go let's go so keep
me in check keep me in check yeah i'm
good let's let's go let's go let's go
this is as far as i got because i got
through the two wet bits just with a
with a freak out yeah and i remember
clambering through this yeah and then we
sort of left you behind at this point
here yeah this point here this will be
very
very sh
the bit with even less headroom i'll
tell you what though
it does mean i'm not nearly as nimble as
before i haven't got quite as much oh
ranger movement there but okay
the next bit is
like that yes but less heavy
less sorry less headroom yeah so a bit
less headroom which means you'll bend
down a little bit meaning the water will
come up a little bit higher
we've been through this neck and heads
up
neck and head's above water i'll be fine
yeah brilliant i'll say i'll be fine
this is this is uncharted territory for
me now
i'm starting to make grumbling noises
is getting on fantastically well
i i'm so happy
i'm just i'm so happy he even decided to
come back
face his fears
and get through it all
you uh you may notice viewers that the
uh the crew have moved our microphones
right like britney mike's on the side of
our faces
and i know that looks ridiculous but
this is
very ah
very
low headroom
here we go so i put my back against the
wall tom i'm gonna i'm just gonna use
the neoprene yeah i think i'm just gonna
float through like this and i'm gonna be
fine
i would be having a bad time if it
weren't for the wetsuit
oh i'm glad i didn't come through here
last time
that would have that would have been a
very bad time
so congratulations tom
all right now that feels patronizing
that does feel patriotic
well done
right
i made it through
like that
don't forget to done raise my hand over
head put a load of cold water down my
back
i mean last time you got to somewhere
that looked beautiful and you're saying
wish you were here
let's get there let's get there tom can
you see on the left here
the light we've got a
straight line almost exactly straight
here this is actually foam and it's a
flood indicator
so
yeah in the past couple of weeks we've
had a few storms like storm eunice for
example and what's happened is that the
water has come up to this line here but
this is meters up from where we were
down there that's why does that sound
hollow it isn't it this is all silks
it's the echo in him
there's a hole under there yeah
wow fantastic so is that i'm assuming
there's solid rocks somewhere back here
oh it's just covered in a massive layer
of silt i mean if you look up a bit
higher you can see the rock oh yeah yeah
so that's where the water hasn't really
come up past that point there
but yeah fantastic isn't it
i'm so glad i got through here all right
i'm just glad that i'm not crouched in
water anymore
so it's onwards through the tube oh
through the tube yeah let's go
so how long does this go for
oh this is
probably a
10 minute walk through this tube here
all right yeah but the thing is that
it's full of boulders as you can see
yeah it's um
last time i was sat for about an hour
that way
well
no i'm fine
it's just that literally 30 seconds
earlier you said mind your head
whack my head into the uh into the roof
nevermind that's why we got the helmets
so
remember how limestone is
oh wow
i don't think i've ever seen
i must have seen soundtrack somewhere
but never close up and never like this
they all they've all got drips on the
end of them because of course that's
what they are yeah so the water is
carrying uh the element that's actually
creating them there these are natural
start tights all from that calcium
carbide in the shells oh i'm so glad i
got through here
incredible isn't it yeah
ah thank you elise
i mean there's still more to go but uh
so what we're going to do is just hop
over the shallow bit of the canyon in a
minute and then we're going to slide
down into the tool a bit it's all fairly
spacious it's just kind of a sideways
shuffled it like a crab walking um if it
ever gets a bit tight on your chest you
can just duck down because it's wide
around your feet so you might want to
just crawl a couple of feet and then
stand up again and see how you get on
okay so this is the kind of that is a
long way down okay that's a little bit
of a leap of faith yeah that's a good uh
good two three meters all right but then
trust your boots yeah it's got a little
bridge um i don't trust the bridge for
some reason
i think i've used it before so there we
go and then when you get here just sit
on your butt like this yep and the
objective is to slide down this bit here
oh it's a
waterfall this is
right it's the it's the worst water
slide i've ever been on got it
i'm just gonna grab your belt yep thank
you very much so one hand there yeah
onto that rock i think i just popped my
in the nose with my elbow sorry about
that
not sure that's better
so this is a vados trench a what a veil
trench right okay so it's again the
water over the years have gone down and
down and down and down just with the
weight of the water making this
very tight place i'm already sideways
you were walking forwards through that
i'm already uh oh yeah okay all right so
you can approach this in two different
ways right uh either standing up or
there's a wider section below so if you
wanted to you could dip down all right
and duck through it instead that's up to
you what you do
yeah i think that i can get through
standing yeah if i if i duck down i
think i'm going to have a worse time
brilliant
last time i didn't understand why you
like caving now i do i get this now no
i'm not
no i'm not constantly freezing cold and
grumpy yeah i get this now i'm glad you
like it
all right so
we're coming to something called
surprise view now
hello pete
and we've got our safety team that's
rigged everything up for us right
so all of these bits here are always on
the wall and we've tested them and
safeguarded them so over the years this
has just been rigged together by people
bringing the gear down to make it
absolutely including a ladder that we're
about to go down okay so somebody would
have gone through the whole cave
handling a ladder all the way to this
point here to screw it onto the wall all
right
we got caught on something there there
we go all right
round and back
oh bloody hell there's a gap there isn't
that
okay that's
yeah that is i see why they call it
surprise view right okay here we go
clear
this is the area now tom yeah where
i really wanted you to be
oh is this the wish you were here this
is the bit where i said that i wished
you were here
and now this is the end point this is
where you got to yes this was so
i was about to say i could get in the
water let me handle my audio
i can just slip over and fall in the
water and it's fine
do you need a hand
he's enjoying himself this is brilliant
this is uh
the end boys
that's the best way to end it isn't it
just
i made it i fell in the water yeah
thank you elise that's all right it's
been a pleasure let's get out of this
cave
folks like you people who watch my
videos tend to be the type of person who
learns best by watching i've seen my
channel statistics my viewers watch
documentaries with hours long video
essays which is why this video has been
sponsored by one dream which might be
exactly what you're looking for when i
make a video i skim the surface because
i have to that's my format one dream is
for anyone who's ever looked at the
stuff i make and thought i'd like to
know more about that a world-class
speech expert has a nine-part lecture
series on mastering personal
communication skills and public speaking
a world-renowned medievalist has a 15
episode course on the black death plus
there are travelogues documentaries
tutorials and how to's the standout for
me was last known coordinates the story
of the first person to stand up
paddleboard across the entire atlantic
ocean solo and unsupported which amazes
me with the idea that for endurance
feats like that it's not about keeping
your body intact it's about managing its
decline and swearing quite a bit one
drum has a free trial so you can
subscribe and start watching without
paying a penny if you go to onedrive.com
tom scott or click the link in the
description you can start your free
trial today support this channel and
maybe find a whole new thing to be
interested in
i'm gonna be glad to get this water out
of my shoes
thank you elise that's okay